hey guys how's it going we are on our
way to Vegas and we've got little Maddy
here
Maddy look how cute you are for those of
you who might have missed the memo
Maddy is a DJ he's currently working on
his album and I really wanted to play a
show in Vegas so we're actually going to
Vegas to see JLo but we thought let's
take Maddy let's see what he thinks in
Vegas and see if he did somewhere that
he wants to maybe play shellac do you
think that you might want to play a show
in Vegas one day scalp locations or in
Matt's new wit check this out
yeah where this the cockpit up I'm
actually your guys's uber driver it's
noon it's 12 o'clock
how long four hours you said three hours
of 15 minutes Casa de Metz probably
gonna take a little longer I'm just
saying now I gotta aim no you're gonna
drive safe can't go over 85 eat more to
play look at me I'm just peeking just be
oh my god okay check it out tenon
actually they said ten and two is not a
good idea anymore yeah cuz you're
supposed to meet Ted and Lotte okay one
is like Jenna I put his little ribbon
here so if you want to play with it well
alright but what if he scratches the
seat
I'll remove the ribbon
[Music]
brother first on genna's getting
Starbucks I'm walking the dog good boy
good boy a really nice day out actually
well those are sharp those are sharp
that's a captain that's a cactus we are
in the desert let's try to corn you
somewhere safe I'm gonna put him in here
and then I'm gonna go peek so I'll come
back cuz I gotta go pee after you oh my
little boy I love you hippie
yep like 15 times professionally nice
shot I forgot this is odd
thanks for coffee welcome it matches
texted us is that to bring a wet towel
because Maddie peed on his leg any
smells I forgot to bring his little
wipes we're at Wendy's I'm quite excited
I'm pretty sure that I would like I
don't know I haven't been here in a long
time I don't remember how their menu
works hi can I have a 2 jr.
cheeseburgers with only ketchup
yeah can I also have a six-piece Chicken
nugget and then one second I got one
more thing a cheeseburger with lettuce
and mayo I also have a cheeseburger with
lettuce and mayo thank you ahh and then
it's it I think that's like they're all
good there okay thank you
I don't Maddie wants something to eat to
a fire it's already done
this is incredible fast food is past man
LLL teach you a meal we made it to the
room but now we're gonna go outside for
a little W which means walk they were so
cute they got Matty little doggie treat
they got a little doggie bag and they
even gave him little dog bowls super
cute
we brought us on great but they actually
do supply crates too so okay honey we're
gonna go outside now okay did you want
to go for a walk so let's go for a walk
there's also this little thing to put on
the door dog in room this is the puppy
potty station it's wild
guys enjoying his nice little walk here
before we take him back up to the room
and before we see JLo I guess I'll give
him some privacy
see you guys we are about to see JLo I
am so excited I feel like we're back at
the game of words because this is where
they were
last year
[Applause]
[Music]
almost home we dropped off Susy now
Maddie has a whole fee to himself
wild times in Vegas see you in the next
video peace
press spoon at seam until pops open a
hostel and poppy
I think everyone did okay let's check
out the pizza the paints oh ha ha ha ha